[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what is up everybody hope you are I do
it well happy Friday / - here max is
joining me today and if you guys watch
video games where it's last night
then you would know apex legends has a
brand new holiday event out and in
action and that's what we're gonna play
today so boom there's gameplay did you
like that uh that Mirage skit that they
did I did a cute little cringy but it
was really cute I liked yeah it was with
like I feel like that's Mirage in a
nutshell yeah cringy oh wait wait wait
oh yeah we wanna I know we're jumping
right into this because that's you know
we're all feeling out right now but
three weeks in three days is when the
winter expressed ends which is a non
Battle Royale format game three teams of
three and you gotta try to capture the
Train everyone gets one life per round
so it's like it's like Search and
Destroy mixed with like king of the hill
type thing yeah it's a mixture of a
whole bunch yeah yeah it's like Search &
Destroy
king of the hill and TDM at the same
time sort of it's kind of weird but I
like it I like that it's kind of
straight from the battle royale for a
second because you could just drop in
just have your weapons immediately you
don't have to worry about looking around
for weapons which is super nice yeah
exactly and so no need to loot every
champ gets their own loadout I think
I've definitely been leaning more
towards breathe slow doubt she has a
pretty good loadout yeah I've been
actually liking Watson because if you do
get the chances to survive long enough
to get her ultimate it's like an instant
win basically because like they only
de-spawn it's like two grenades and if
he just like fence up what are the
trains like impossible for them to do
anything about it
I'll try and do that interesting it's
taking a while already but but the whole
thing is super adorable like the whole
event
it's very holiday II all the skins are
really nice to actually watch this game
times where DQ she's got a cool beanie
on uh else oh yeah and the trailer he's
like Watson let's take an LM d gz stuff
like that though yeah all these skins
are really cool actually this is taking
a while to miss you yeah some pretty bad
matchmaking right now maybe when I went
earlier when I was playing earlier I got
into matches super quick
yeah I did too just oh yeah sure I get
it yeah I really like gibbie's he's like
a polar bear yeah it's such a cool stuff
it's actually gonna affect his hitbox
looks it's pretty massive
that's so much stuff it's like a Teddy
polar bear yeah he's got like a toboggan
as like a that's pretty cool cold out
Bangalore's for some reason I know her
stuff is always like so intimidating
it's like it's Christmas Bangalore
Arthur you know one's pretty dope - oh
wow that is pretty but I don't know how
like the sights look reminds me of a
keyblade I've been playing a lot what is
going on with this winter Express here
this is pretty bad let me uh give her
more of this stuff while we're waiting
for a game oh I like froze for a second
but maybe
good yeah he's the perfect Santa of
course I mean besides being evil at all
look for sure this this haircut is
almost exactly reminiscent of overwatch
freakin shield boy oh right like the
exact same haircut as Reinhart which is
pretty funny some gun charms oh I just
seen for the first time in pathfinders
heirloom set is like a pair of box so
that's not quick video of that online
where they did the emote for it but they
inspect animation for it and it's really
long first of all and second of all like
it's really in-depth he's got like
little like hologram the Holograms but
he's got those little screens in the
back of these gloves and they change so
like when he's running these X super
like happy yeah it's really cool and
then uh yeah it's like doing like the
punch animation as soon as like it
starts to end like Carter comes in the
bird and he punches the oh my lord what
is going on with this magic making
should I try to search in the regular
let's try to do regular mash regular
match first we'll try to go to mirages
voice
[Music]
that's weird I've never seen it like not
loaded at all before because I
definitely was playing like not too long
ago also in the chat I want to hear what
you guys think if you guys are apex
players about uh
the shadow sorry background matchmaking
that's been going on recently
let's want to hear your guys input first
see what you guys background matchmaking
yeah what's that that's uh it's it's
been a new implementation in the last
like three weeks I feel like it's been
Oh skill based matchmaking
and it's been a some point of contention
good and bad just want to hear you guys
input and see what you guys are thinking
wow this is I know I'm about to restart
at my application we might have to
restart here cuz I'm not sure if this is
actually a yeah one second you guys all
right hold up we're gonna restart her
yeah we're gonna applications and all
that jazz you know how it goes okay this
is like the modern-day equivalent to
like taking the cartridge out I'm going
on the application I see that with us
Smash Bros on n64 the cartridge on that
was very dusty for some reason there's
something about it yeah alrighty
restarting in here
[Music]
big chunk is alright let's so when this
game works it's great yeah whoa those
are like already up in the party or I
was weird
okay let's try yeah we'll go to Winter
Street more time don't feel worse I
heard people are having problems logging
in yesterday but I thought that was just
because of high traffic right this might
just be another issue in itself so we
were just playing a second ago
whatever itchy I am not Iranian Persia
is my handle not my real name which a
lot of people do think is my real name
yes I mean that's not an uncommon real
name
that's a the possible real name right I
think someone else in the office
actually is named Cujo like your real
name I was like man I thought I was
using my hands also like oh yeah finally
please like us like ten minutes all
right here we go
mirages so funny yeah he's such a
character I don't like playing as him
but I definitely like just enjoy his
spectacle I've been watching all these
videos in fact he does a really good
like voice-activated system he goes and
he plays and he's actually pretty good
and everyone's always like yo you sound
just like Mirage and he does like the
same little quips and everything oh
really
I almost did really fun playing online
with him yeah my trolling other people
you should like to see those videos when
I get a chance
boys trolling videos there's probably
something funny yeah I remember the old
school like Widowmaker ones from ok
you're the jumpmaster with my spray tan
yeah you have one life per round
you win by either eliminating it or
happening
oh no oh no I fell off the okay
so honcho
we are playing the new limited mode so
no booting in this mode and on every
round it's like specific style
yep and then its first three opposite
got body but that's okay yeah I
accidentally missed the cliff and then
fell straight onto the tree so there's a
couple things to the line when you play
this mode you guys is like you can
straight-up win if the other teams not
on the train and it's unlocked
that happens to me like twice already
where I went around straight up by oh I
love the John Nelson Baba's going in
here
Oh Oh there is definitely people holding
I don't know my ability yet I'm gonna
die Oh
[Music]
see they're already on it
oh okay I got I got one I'm gonna die
Oh terrified I really want to get this
ultimate that's also worth noting is
that let's say a team captures the
street but doesn't you're still fighting
people in between the trains it's like
don't think the rounds over over like
yeah so I guess it's kind of better to
try to eliminate your I mean you can't
just think up to the appositive girls to
get your old I'm almost there
the wrong train to do it on
[Music]
why is this place so fat for today's
presents
okay I see people two people on top of
the Sun
let's gather supplies
it's gonna keep it going for a second
here tonight this stuff
[Music]
yeah I really like this even though we
did not win that round wait whoever
kills it could have just captured that
yeah exactly see this I was saying
earlier sometimes to the cat I can't
wait
see what they're doing you know we just
kind of sit here
the Train which you guys made those
little low strings and the tracks or
those like jump pads I think you can use
those to kind of catch up to the train
trains moving
he's a responder
yeah it'll slow the goods you got to
give people time on the train to like
reload their shields and stuff yeah I
wish I could somebody else
I see are we going
very much
[Music]
I have to gone
[Music]
well
stop with the dream for a moment
Hey hi
the only squad on the tray they're using
my Watson ultimate to know one thing
like but this is like like Battle Royale
and I just wanted to do like a I don't
know if that's team A or B
real workers definitely a good
the music so we got our champion I know
it's pretty great even sport even at the
end like ended perfectly I okay that was
just the first game okay isn't ranking
us with some crazy people I doubt it I
don't really like play a rank at all
over so I don't think it has much to
like compare me to you know I don't know
i've i've been playing ranked and it's
less it's easier to play ranked than it
is casuals right now oh really
interesting it's that crazy on casual
MLG pro
my life plain old legends for you guys
because they have different loadouts
switch your legend in between rounds yes
all right this will be fun
can't wait to win we load it into this
one really fast yeah that was quick
Merry Christmas Mulsanne we're movin up
you gotta hit what he's building for
some time
yeah about that one
I'm going to keep an eye over there on
it already
I'll be kind of smart about
like yeah there are some trout's down
I'm so lucky I saw like somebody fly in
was that a different squad was that
their squad that was responding because
that was really quick like there's also
these launch pads all right that's those
characters yeah sure
[Music]
top of this thing
stopping at this station
I thought I actually stuck her with the
art star
oh wait it's me back to read know what
the best strategy is there's to be
passive way for them to fight but we
can't do that because then it could
capture the transact like I don't know
what I like that it makes this thing man
Team B is really uh they're really doing
it I think we just need to
well I get some high ground yeah that uh
that Pathfinder that's like I wasn't a
deer had a father literally zero audio
and a whole clip on my plane and landing
one shot let's go M vez
shoot out that
kostik
[Music]
how many people
elimination the squad has won this round
rack up those points
like there's just an extended heavy
looks like there's a new cheerleader
now it's like what do we do
[Music]
oh all right stick it down
[Music]
let's go
once the time starts wiggling down like
the two teams take to battling abuse it
goes to the center Colonel you know it's
like if your car doesn't have a have a
cover on it okay well I don't like no
actual visual to tell me that exactly
there's a few things I feel like they
don't explain very well yeah but yeah
that was still a good run
yeah we're getting better at this got a
couple frags I'm okay with that
all right back yet it I'm definitely a
fan of the havoc with turbo I wish I
could see the load out from here because
I like don't have much time - yeah it's
true
spitfyre Mozambique
I think I got your back man let me tell
you
Achtung was really weird but it did I
never seen autism my pleasure
they're looking for you oh I don't know
yet thank you I hate to play with a
cowboy on the lock everybody here's your
oh I'm the Jeff master alrighty then
well that's it here we go is ready yup
my plan has a longer range eleven
I think the smart thing to do here is a
third party every single time just kind
of stay out of the fight for a second
and then kind of jump in yeah maybe
after like you capture the train and it
goes in between rounds I get off the
train and then use the guys there's like
fly up again and real and
[Applause]
oh I got one maybe that's not the strike
because they just there's what you told
us I know and then the group that went
straight to the train game a chance and
luck honestly the train the train
provides like just enough cover I think
[Music]
okay maybe the stride is just kind of
land near the Train but not on it and
just kind of troops advisor said I sat
in queue for like 20 minutes to make
sure I need to play this so I just left
well we were kind of having troubles at
first but we restarted the application
maybe try again today land right here
returned to the battlefield oh dang I
didn't want to jump all the way down
look it's fine it's fine everything
slamming around me and I don't know
where they are they're already on it
wait up
I feel like we did not win that even
though they like happy and last second I
don't understand really does
where are you guys the confusion
yeah I'm all
definitely got these party
give you chased me all the way around
the mountain but the only reason I made
it back on the train for that oh so
that's like I know I was like if you
really chasing
about that it stays in place
oh my super load just you versus her
okay what the hell look like right now
she look normal on my stream but nearest
food
that was weird okay oh my RA can he win
this y'all
[Music]
I really wish us playing Lawson right
now
like on my ultinice
okay
you know like the other team had two
rounds they see it one more up close one
max Blumenthal epic apex legends and
breath of the wild player why yes it is
Evan
it is indeed poof all right that was fun
that was fun this mode is is really I
don't know they said he predicted that
this was the run you're right you're
right another yeah there's like a happy
medium that you have to do you like not
too aggressive but not too passive at
the same time just like kind of around
the Train but not in the train is like
kind of the best flight they feel like
any prize for winning you know that
personal satisfaction yeah goldstar I
think there are some skins and stuff
that are specific to that well you get
this badge for winning three times I
mean that's not really but there is some
skins for the L star and I think if you
abide in my entourage
he had a cold skin oh really
but I heard from a fellow player he was
like and then he did it and he's like no
acting he's very good it might be chance
there was like at least 40 people there
- it was crazy
oh well I would not ever played on the
jump master
we're gonna do the starting tonight
we're laying on top of this building
[Music]
I mean if we can't see in there forever
but obviously I could get like a lay of
the land
we can jump down for that
oh and Eric and getting everyone job I
think we're c-plus Eric yeah you guys
don't mind us
there was nowhere to run
he's on the other train mission yeah
it's a young locker skimmer yeah as a
challenge for something we get one kill
with each legend on this game time but
yep I'm not I just hate the triple tanks
I don't mind it
the sign so long ago I think it's my
favorite sniper I mean it can be used
hey they land with us or no no they're
all separated
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
now it's like should we hop on a geyser
and real and and get another list I feel
like we should goes like being on the
train it's like a tight I AMA try it go
jump on this one right here
now the other thing is like they could
shoot you
I do
yeah okay I just heard crazy somebody
but that guy got destroyed yeah we gotta
hit the guys there yeah I feel like we
shouldn't be on the train when it rolls
in this is just a big target a jury
charge ratios
all right so one source starts I guess
bullying
yeah I think in the tunnel I'm gonna
dropout
[Music]
I feel like I'm in a shopping mall right
now here's something music
[Music]
Oh crab had all the train okay no see
that was not purpose but that's fine I
think we could probably show for a
second I don't know how many geysers are
up front but might be able to take one
from the other side
where's you far yeah we are a little
we've committed
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
no I knew it can be a bad idea to go on
coughing occurs like that
okay I believe it
[Music]
chose on it too right
yeah but I wasn't tired that's the only
notification you get center cart a
sensor whoever is left is like I think
camping out
I mean this might just go tiny I was
like time over and we're gonna respond
they still have to fight each other
though I guess
oh I didn't realize I was driving okay
should give you a countdown or something
okay Eric just pulled in
super wheat super weak up on top well
just get in the center crew yeah she's
going all the way around he was still on
the tree
[Music]
who they're still fighting on the train
that's good news for us
yeah oh that actually kind of sucks
actually kind of sucks like if you think
about it like you survive and he goes in
next night not only to get low ammo but
if they're like attacking you then
you're gonna be weak when all the other
squads dropping yeah
[Music]
I like being jumpmaster
I can't see anything
I noticed this audio really happy
and they are not the only squad on the
train
that's right right yeah yeah her
loadouts really good oh my goodness I'm
so glad she turned around when I
switched weapons I was like oh no all
right good stuff good job team that was
another close one it was like a lesson
team a or my gut King is cute all right
I think I'm definitely a Bangalore fan
autumn winter express for some reason
I'm gonna try out every character though
Kryptos is pretty cool I mean nothing
was a big part but actually having the
drone overhead might be nice yeah I got
hit with a drone in one of my matches
earlier that was but then he was so far
away from the light rain that
I know what I'm doing I've got your back
and I'm gonna tell you is the only
secure way to go so the P 2020 and this
set up with the bloodhound specifically
has a more point that's why there's so
much damage but it's weird cuz I don't
think kryptos has hammer pointed his
nose in deep it has like a gold
attachment yeah the digital threat the
hammer point so it's kind of weird
alright Saints try it with me over here
another
the bullets refresh you to change
character Matheny you call you change it
mid-round so yeah they always go to
school
oh they landed with us this is the audio
issue of Makarov I should not hear that
personnel
oh man that raped
I'm afraid you'll mud I think he wanted
to die maybe wanted a watch it might be
a smart move for you right now yeah I'm
so far away it's fine I'll eventually
get over there
okay I've got a geyser
I have to look around me constantly cuz
I don't know
alright I'm on my way
so I just saw blood on top of this
building already heard him use the
shield
good
all right thank you that far so good
those guys are so awesome
it'll be pretty cool yeah they go really
far
once it's those players are responding
that's when I'm gonna jump out and get
on so guising okay cuz then we can see
their trail or where they go that's
smart
oh and I get to see them ahead of time
we can a lid on top of this
Oh doh
[Music]
no lifeline blanks me there's literally
like one person on the favoring your
throne to confess the Train
[Music]
oh my god that freaking hammer point
hurt
[Music]
yeah that was more of like it's fine I
see someone in chat is just now
realizing for the first time that
console shooters have auto aim I mean
it's nothing crazy yeah and also nothing
new yeah auto assist but it's literally
been on every single like console
shooter I've ever played you can turn it
off though but you didn't way back in
like old Halo games so the same exact
way I know this because you would be
trying to snipe someone and someone run
behind them and it would like drag your
eyes oh I know so the the best way to
play apex when you're teaming up against
multiple is to be sort of near each
other because what happens is like the
aim assist doesn't know who to target
and elect driver yeah that's the best
way to like screw with people's aim
assist is to be sort of together it
actually does work really well because
I've been destroyed by that multiple
times where I just can't hit it right
just hit between them because it doesn't
know which one to pick yeah but it's not
like a shroud like lock on aim it's like
yeah when you're like hovering over
their body it just slows your your
sensitivity pretty much like ever so
slightly and I should just pull without
even touching the controls to you
sometimes like I'm used to sometimes
where I'm just like aim down the sights
and I just hold it there to see if
anybody like goes in that general
direction even if they're behind a wall
sometime so like it'll just like drag
for a second like Oh somebody's there
because it moved for a second yeah but
that's again the same rule with every
single person even if you go on like PC
version and you plug in a controller
it'll automatically turn on
emesis area if you didn't have a Masson
it's not like some GTA aim-assist type
like it's just enough to help y'all not
enough to be game-breaking
yeah this is every console this is
switch Xbox ps4 it's not there is auto
aim assist you see another all right
here we go squab
if you have a respiratory system okay
[Music]
is that how I do it
like a full predator squad over there
that's
Wow oh my gosh it's quite bad I actually
[Applause]
Wow actually no they that's bad for them
yeah they're far away yeah that's a
comeback
[Music]
landing next to us yeah
Oh No by you before do you need to
recharge my shields person he's on the
other side I just
that was thank you for cleaning
[Music]
all right
[Music]
mad bro they're all on the roof
Renet
I don't get second I step on top of the
Train everybody shoots at me
this one's hanging on top of the tree
for light up around hate that yeah this
Watson team is pretty sweaty
[Music]
wonder if that's team team watch me also
we're competing squad has won this round
[Music]
I know it's holiday flavor but this
music this doesn't really quite fit but
I know I told you for the holidays I
like it I like just the bombastic epic
orchestra stuff that they have during a
drop it's so good we got to try to check
out the Mirage blush after this is it a
separate it's a it's just a town
takeover oh okay right yeah they have
like the supply ships
I'm gonna rush them somebody's coming in
my mark firing for effect
I was stuck in that stink forever
all right so for last game let's go and
take out this let's go check out Mirage
Mirage I wonder how many drop ships
there are just college I just thought
just the one well the one game I played
so far it was kind of just or didn't
move
it looked stationary okay so we'll see
if it's in the same spot if it's like
the kings canyon one and we're like it
originally moved to like a spot and then
just stayed there so I don't know if
that's the same with this the one match
I played it was already stationary I was
already there okay yeah this is the kind
of music you snap your face yeah it's a
mood for sure like when I walk around
stores now and they're playing Christmas
music I'm like oh yeah it is almost
Christmas at least I don't know it may
be just in my area but I feel like the
Christmas didn't hit me so hard like in
November this year yeah yeah usually
they just skip over Thanksgiving and
they're like yeah I'm seeing all these
like stockings and Christmas stuff on
the walls are like November 15th I'm
like dude it's been more than a month
away we'll have max open his loot boxes
after this game okay
you know I think this is gonna be a good
fight good luck have fun don't die
I don't think you could drop as far as I
know I haven't tried I feel like you
could I think I sought a drop his scope
for as long though as just using an iron
sights for it I don't think a drop your
gun be good to try it kind of cool like
swap yeah that's real steam strats oh
yeah
[Music]
all right where is it it's oh it's over
there yeah everyone's gonna go baby so
spicy
yeah look at my plate earlier literally
every single spot drop I think we're
gonna the Stratus to drop near it then
go towards it but the party alright
pretty lights we die quick we will try
it one more slow music
the boomers are say
oh man is Yolo boom richer it's so
pretty
oh boy oh boy
oh my god is plainly
freaking crazy I need ammo
someone's revising I got it
all these mirages like colognes in here
uh psyching me out
I've already fired at him like three
times I'm cam please arrived yeah let me
revive you in a second
we survived and you were worried max you
know look at Mirage hanging out of here
oh we get to taking all this ice now
that's pretty dope
I'm actually shocked only one os5 booty
news was pretty one
oh he can actually kill the mirages it's
pretty cool
all right I think oh my god
turbocharger
I need light ammo if anybody's
yeah I think we all do I need to get off
we need to get off
this part is dead always the Mirage the
trailer that's really funny one minute
the ring isn't far some barrels
we're just having her knee oh man this
is all covered in snow now
oh don't kill me there's nothing show
off we got really lucky only like some
spot shotgun yeah what am I waiting for
I'm going nuts back in the ring I'll be
there very interesting and extended
heavy bag here helmet here yeah no
thanks Evan I can't play up the wingman
garbage to me I'm already standing
energy back here
level 2 stand their stock here level 1
it's made it so far
Oh
humming care package is a purple shield
a lot
you know for all that fighting that we
did on that we got like no loot yeah I
know you like I was hoping there's gonna
be some awesome loot on the voyage yeah
those kind of trash all right you want
to run this again all right I feel like
the first time I went like 20 squads
went there
oh I'm sure like when the game first
when it first dropped yeah I'm sure that
there's a lot of people going there I
feel like we should go there's a bottom
area like below the train tracks there's
a whole bunch of loot there we should go
there first
okay oh wait your loot boxes oh that's
right open your loot although these are
not the seasonal again
[Music]
that was trashed I never get anything
good I randomly sign in when I like 15
pack
[Music]
I think I got like one purple thing I'm
in the same boat as you
I didn't get purple alright last match
of the Streamy again let me go on with
my own after playing winter Express and
going back to the Battle Royale where
after Lou and like yeah
yeah I just like going in and gun and I
don't want to look around for a little
accolade hope to god that I don't run
into a peacekeeper when I have no
shields like where'd they get a nurse
the peacekeepers this is going suppose
it did I still get one shot at with that
so what can you do
all right we got this
[Music]
get those stats Fontes account this is
you those Octane's that who's your mate
ah drivin really subtle but I haven't
using Pathfinder a bit more and I kind
of hop around you don't have like one
dedicated one yeah I've got a good
feeling about this area dropping in here
though
hang on easy to kind of be like
or if someone else picked someone I want
and not a big deal yeah
Wow people are over it already they're
like whatever don't care
oh man a group landed here across from
us I got two shotguns you need a weapon
I have some pistols very near my going
from behind oh she's so low
Jeremy good job she had a lot yeah
definitely needed that all right where
we going but her team is definitely
abandon her because there was like two
people in last and I guess the other
person goes bounce that's messed up
unless they're just here still somewhere
I feel like we should go okay
maybe something good this way
porky here reloading hell maybe should
get that I'll pick it up
I've got a vault key I need to heal I
should go inside here Chris unless I am
repairing myself oh yeah I hear the
footsteps are the firecrackers oh yeah
that's a good question because now that
is listen it's kind of something for ya
what thank you no no I think it's just
playful I am preparing myself that
Mirage Mirage with a spectacle but
sweaty people are very good I only saw
like minimal amounts of squad strawberry
there are shiny trails
is that what that means yep Wow why is
that a thing because I don't know why
don't they just put all the predator
people together
someone's ex me all right let's see if I
can alright I'm going to stay here
they're gonna body okay one guy's handsy
you totally rampant so-and-so I try to
run the opposite way I don't have
anything that is exactly what I'm
talking about predators come in take
these paper in one shot that's what apex
has become these days I was gonna put my
stance on background matchmaking but
that's what happens you these you do one
one good game and then you're like oh
you must be a predator so I'm gonna put
you other the Predators all right well I
think unless we want to try it one more
or maybe one more winter Express
yeah the winter Express is a little
quicker I think all right we'll do one
more winter Express and then and then
we're done Zell for the day y'all I'm
gonna hit the weekend
get ready Christmas is around the corner
hope you guys are you know got all your
gifts I feel like it's been a long time
since I got an actual gift like wrapped
in with a bow and the whole deal I don't
think I've done that right you just
start to just give your friends stuff
like in the packaging you're like chuck
it on the ground in front of yourself
I'm a Bangla fan sites like our normal
anything but just in the our 99 against
me cuz what's a knowledge that have that
sometimes oh yeah yeah it's a pretty
good loadout all the way don't like the
attachment so that are they Olin
actually yeah turn it off
it's so weird cuz it's like they give
you blue backpack stand your friends
like no I'm the master of the jump he
says say Molesey whatever this is the
best part
oh the hub is one of the right honors
Haley is right alone and I don't think
there's any book
this might be an all-out brawl
Oh
[Music]
no they're on it
my father squad has boarded the train my
shields of recharge
something I'd really like I don't our
teen says it's all cool but now I say it
i sell--
across France both will be geyser time
[Music]
just a tad before
[Music]
hey you tropical
go to the enemy all dinner taking a
geyser
so check out here that's such a cool
jump
train is stopping at this station I've
made a mistake a grave grave mistake
Oxana was just on the other side of the
train
he was
again it's the earth real ones Devil's
Lake wasn't so slow we've been a lot
more useful for sure
[Music]
yeah they're over there dangles five
oh geez go over here - oh god I don't
know where to go back to the genes just
supporting someone out there watch your
dumb thing here somebody coming in why
are all these jump pads in the way for
I can't run into safety
all go away and the blank you
we doesn't need one more round the
faceoff in the center card there was two
squats against each other there was like
one person left and of course they're
shooting at now we train which you guys
all missed did I mention that you guys
lost this round there's somebody won the
Train round yeah this is some pretty bad
leg oh this is some proof
let me go give me a sec recharging shoe
Nana I'm getting completely stuck on
everything
always someone on top
big jump
all right writing will help you some
apex legends with us we definitely did
this new events pretty dope okay hope
you guys get a chance to check it out
until next time though we'll see you
later see ya
you